este es un control remoto universal y
hoy vamos a desmontarlo para ver qué es
lo que tiene dentro y ver qué es lo que
lo hace funcionar para esto hay dos
tipos diferentes de controles remotos
universales están los controles remotos
inteligentes o de aprendizaje y los que
funcionan con librerías de código y de
hecho éste funciona con librerías los
controles remotos inteligentes suelen
ser más costosos ya que si pones el
control remoto original a un lado
básicamente estás utilizando el control
remoto original para programar el
control remoto inteligente y así podrá
funcionar como decía son más costosos y
más complejos este control ya tiene una
librería de código incorporada así que
si introduces cierta secuencia de
números extra es cierto código y después
de eso podrás activar cualquier
dispositivo que vaya con ese código
ahora para ahorrar tiempo ya había
cortado en la caja así que vamos a sacar
el control remoto bien puedes ver que
hay un montón de diferentes botones cada
uno desarrolla diferentes funciones
también por aquí hay un pequeño led un
diodo emisor de luz que se enciende
justo aquí y bueno ahora vamos a retirar
la parte de atrás esta es una pequeña
etapa para las baterías la cual está
moldeada por inyección y puedes rotarlo
por muchas razones una de ellas es que
está hecha de una manera muy precisa y
la otra es que tiene estas pequeñas
marcas de pernos del inyector estos
pequeños círculos fueron los pernos que
se usan para empujar la pieza fuera del
molde después de que se hizo y de hecho
también puedes ver justo aquí que dice
plástico abs así que es una pieza de
plástico abs y el abs es bastante
económico y resistente al impacto y es
que todos sabemos que los controles
remotos tienden a caerse voltearse así
que eligen un buen plástico para estas
caídas
vamos a ver si podemos sacar esto de
aquí aquí vamos
muy bien esto está moldeado juntos
bien
y estos aparatos utilizan algo llamado
ajuste de interferencia o también es
llamado encaje a precisión la cubierta
inferior y la cubierta superior están
hechas de plástico abs pueden verlo de
nuevo aquí justo tenemos el símbolo de
abs el símbolo de reciclaje del plástico
y también puedes ver que tenemos estos
realces o distanciador es que lo que
hacen es mantener la placa del circuito
en su lugar
estas son pequeñas pestañas que permiten
que se mantengan unidas la razón por la
que no tienen ningún tornillo es porque
ayudan a reducir el costo este control
remoto es muy barato y reducir costos es
una manera clave para producirlo por una
baja cantidad y seguir haciendo dinero
con su venta bien pueden ver que aquí
tenemos varios componentes diferentes
estas cosas estos resultados de aquí son
donde las baterías se conectan también
puedes observar que hay resortes al
interior de esta parte inferior y otros
por acá y parece ser que usa baterías
triple a la energía va de estos resortes
hacia el otro lado de la placa y aquí
tenemos lo que parece una resistencia
tal vez un filtro de algún tipo y por
acá tenemos un capacitor dieléctrico y
arriba tenemos un led infrarrojo de
manera que su luz brilla en el espectro
infrarrojo por lo que no puedes verlo
con tus ojos pero si tuviéramos una
cámara infrarroja podrías verlo brillar
con su destello de luz y bueno ya que no
podemos ver el infrarrojo es un tanto
agradable porque no quisiéramos ver la
luz brillando constantemente en tu
televisor o en tu estéreo y porque
tenemos un led indicador así que vamos a
quitar esto de aquí vamos a dejar la
placa de circuito impreso por ejm vamos
a quitar los botones
estos son los botones y bueno otra razón
para usar el modelo por inyección es
porque es muy preciso por eso puedes
obtener un ajuste muy limpio y agradable
es por eso que los botones encajan muy
bien justo aquí y también estos botones
son una manera de reducir costos porque
no hay resortes que regresen los botones
lo que pasa es que
por sí mismo llamado santo print tiene
una resistencia particular lo que causa
que el botón regrese a su ubicación
original después de ser presionado y
esto sin necesidad de resortes y por
aquí tenemos estos pequeños contactos
conductivos justo debajo y estos
contactos constructivos conectan estos
pequeños dedos expuestos cuando el botón
es presionado estas pequeñas partes no
estoy seguro si puedes verlas claramente
pero estas diminutas partes de aquí
éstas tienen estos contactos
entrelazados expuestos y de hecho tienen
esta forma ya que cuando presionas el
botón provoca que el conductor de la
parte posterior entre en contacto con
estos dedos expuestos y eso hace que el
impulso eléctrico sea enviado a este
tipo de aquí este de aquí es un pequeño
circuito integrado y es él el que tiene
almacenadas las librerías de código y
además del prêt à de señales de cada uno
de estos interruptores es decir si
quieres ver el canal 4 presionas el 4
activas esta conexión de aquí y esta
cosa les dice a las baterías que envíen
la energía al led y este parpadea el dt
infrarrojo parpadea en un patrón
particular y ese patrón va a ser
interpretado por tu exterior o por tu
televisor y provocan que el estéreo o el
televisor cambio de estación o de canal
y ahora puedes ver por aquí en la parte
posterior que toda esta placa está hecha
de fibra de vidrio y tiene una capa
delgada de cobre aplicada en la parte
posterior puedes ver que en algunos
lugares el cobre ha sido retirado
observa las partes donde se ve verde más
claro es donde hay cobre y las partes
donde es más oscuro no hay pobre y lo
que hace es que permite crear algo
parecido a cables que conectan todo
entre sí el cobre actúa como un cable es
un conductor y los espacios entre el
cobre funcionan como un aislante y es
por eso que no tenemos ningún corto
estas pequeñas conexiones de corre de
aquí permiten que la corriente fluya y
envíe señales de vuelta al
microprocesador este es el
microprocesador y es el que interpreta
las señales y después envía las señales
al dt infrarrojo el cual envía la señal
hacia tu televisor y si por ejemplo
tuviéramos una cámara infrarroja
podríamos ver las diferentes secuencias
que salen de este leer al parpadear y
estas son las que activan los cambios en
tu televisor o el dow estéreo y para que
no se prorrogan estos contactos están
recubiertos y así queda aislado
comúnmente lo aíslan con una capa de
laca y este material brillante de aquí
es llamado soldadura y básicamente lo
que hace es sujetar conectores como éste
al otro lado de la placa y asegurarse de
que haya una conexión conductora para
que la energía de la batería sea enviada
a la placa
en fin de cualquier manera esto es lo
que hay adentro de un control remoto
universal